qui, comme on le sait tous,
caractérise tous les lieux de travail aux États-Unis.
Il y a des milliers d'images comme celles-là.
Il suffit de chercher « mère active » sur un moteur de recherche
ou un site d'images.
Elles sont partout sur le net,
couvrant les articles de blogs et d'information,
et elles m'ont obsédée, avec le message mensonger qu'elles véhiculent
et le confort qu'elles nous procurent,
qu'en ce qui concerne les nouvelles mamans actives en Amérique,
tout va bien.
Mais tout ne va pas bien.
Notre pays renvoie des millions de femmes au travail
chaque année, étonnamment et terriblement tôt,
après qu'elles ont accouché.
C'est un problème moral
mais aujourd'hui, je vous dirai aussi pourquoi c'est un problème économique.
J'étais tellement irritée et obsédée par le caractère peu réel de ces images,
qui ne ressemblent en rien à ma vie,
que j'ai décidé de réaliser et poser dans une série de photos parodiques,
en espérant que le monde les utilise.
Elles montrent l'étrange réalité de retourner au travail
alors que la source alimentaire de ton enfant est attachée à votre corps.
Je ne vous montrerai que deux d'entre elles.
(Rires)
Rien n'incite à accorder une promotion à une femme,
aussi bien qu'une fuite de lait durant une présentation.
Vous voyez qu'il n'y a pas de bébé sur cette photo,
parce que cela ne fonctionne pas ainsi,
pas pour la plupart des mères actives.
Saviez-vous que, et ça va gâcher votre journée
chaque fois qu'on tire la chasse d'eau,
les bactéries sont propulsées dans l'air et y restent des heures ?
Pourtant, pour de nombreuses jeunes mamans actives,
pendant la journée, cela est le seul lieu où elles peuvent
faire à manger à leur bébé.
J'en ai fait une dizaine comme celle-ci à travers le monde.
Je voulais faire passer un message.
Je ne savais pas que j'ouvrais aussi une porte.
Maintenant, de nombreuses inconnues m'écrivent de partout
et tout le temps
pour me raconter comment se passe leur retour au travail
quelques jours ou quelques semaines après l'accouchement.
Aujourd'hui, je vais partager avec vous 10 de ces histoires.
Elles sont toutes vraies, certaines sont très crues
et aucune ne ressemble à cela.
Voici la première.
« J'étais en activité dans une prison fédérale.
J'ai repris le travail après les huit semaines autorisées pour ma césarienne.
Un collègue était agacé que je sois partie en « vacances ».
Il a volontairement ouvert la porte alors que je tirais du lait
et est resté sur le seuil donnant sur les détenus dans le couloir. »
La plupart des histoires que m'envoient ces femmes inconnues
ne sont plus vraiment liées à l'allaitement.
Une femme m'a écrit, disant :
« J'ai accouché de jumeaux et j'ai repris le travail après sept semaines non payées.
Moralement, j'étais brisée.
Physiquement, j'avais eu une forte hémorragie et une grosse déchirure
au point d'à peine pouvoir me lever, m’asseoir ou marcher.
Mon employeur m'a dit que je ne pouvais pas poser mes congés acquis
en raison de la saison budgétaire. »
J'en suis venue à croire qu'on refuse de regarder ces situations en face
car quand on le fait, elles nous horrifient,
et si on est horrifiés, on devra alors faire quelque chose.
On choisit alors de regarder et de croire cette image.
Je ne sais pas trop ce qu'il se passe sur cette image,
je la trouve étrange et un peu inquiétante.
(Rires)
Mais que fait-elle ?
Mais ce qu'elle nous transmet,
c'est que tout va bien.
Cette femme active et toutes les autres ainsi que leurs bébés vont bien.
Il n'y a rien à voir ici.
Et puis, les femmes ont fait un choix,
ce n'est en aucun cas notre problème.
J'aimerais diviser ce choix en deux parties.
Le premier est que les femmes ont choisi de travailler.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Aujourd'hui, les femmes représentent 47% de la main d'œuvre,
et pour 40% des ménages américains,
la femme est le soutien financier unique ou principal de la famille.
Notre emploi salarié est une grande partie du moteur de notre économie,
et est essentiel au fonctionnement de nos familles.
À l'échelle nationale, notre travail n'est pas une option.
Le 2ème choix est que les femmes ont choisi d'avoir des enfants,
elles doivent, à elles seules, en assumer les conséquences.
C'est le genre de phrase
qui peut sonner juste si on l'entend sans y prêter attention.
« Je ne t'ai pas forcée à avoir un bébé.
Je n'étais pas là quand c'est arrivé. »
Mais cette position ignore une réalité fondamentale :
notre procréation à l'échelle nationale n'est pas une option.
Les bébés qu'ont aujourd'hui les femmes, actives pour la plupart,
feront un jour partie de notre force de travail, protègeront nos côtes,
constitueront notre assiette fiscale.
Notre procréation à l'échelle nationale n'est pas une option.
Ce ne sont pas des choix.
Nous avons besoin que les femmes travaillent et qu'elles aient des enfants.
Ne devrions-nous pas rendre ces tâches simultanées
supportables au moins ?
Bon, c'est l'heure du quiz :
à votre avis, quel est le pourcentage de femmes aux États-Unis
qui n'ont pas le droit aux congés maternité payés ?
88%.
88% des femmes actives n'auront pas une minute de congé payé
après l'accouchement.
Vous pensez peut-être alors au congé non payé.
Il existe aux États-Unis, c'est le FMLA. Cela ne fonctionne pas.
A cause de sa structure et de toutes sortes d'exceptions,
50% des nouvelles mères y sont inéligibles.
Voilà à quoi ça ressemble.
« Nous avons adopté notre fils.
Quand on m'a appelée le jour de sa naissance,
j'ai dû partir du travail.
Je n'avais pas assez d'ancienneté pour avoir droit au FMLA,
je n'étais donc pas éligible pour les congés non-payés.
En prenant mon congé pour voir mon fils nouveau-né,
j'ai perdu mon poste. »
Ces galeries de photos d'entreprises cachent une autre réalité.
Pour celles qui ont le droit à ces congés non-payés,
la plupart ne peuvent pas du tout se permettre d'en prendre.
Une infirmière m'a dit : « Je n'avais pas le droit à une invalidité
de courte durée car ma grossesse est vue comme un état préexistant.
Nous avons épuisé tous nos revenus et la moitié de nos économies
durant mes 6 semaines non-payées.
Nous ne pouvions plus continuer.
Physiquement, c'était dur. Moralement, c'était pire.
J'ai souffert pendant des mois d'être loin de mon fils. »
Reprendre le travail si tôt est une décision économique rationnelle
liée aux finances de la famille.
Mais cela est souvent physiquement éprouvant
car mettre une vie au monde, cela chamboule tout.
Une serveuse m'a dit :
« Avec mon 1er enfant, j'ai repris le travail 5 semaines après l'accouchement.
Pour mon 2e, j'ai dû subir une lourde chirurgie après l'accouchement,
j'ai donc attendu 6 semaines avant de reprendre.
J'avais une déchirure du 3ème degré. »
23% des nouvelles mères actives aux États-Unis
reprennent le travail dans les 2 semaines suivant l'accouchement.
« J'étais serveuse et cuisinière
75 heures par semaine pendant ma grossesse.
J'ai dû reprendre le travail avant que mon fils ait un mois
et travailler 60 h par semaine.
Une collègue n'a pu s'offrir que 10 jours de congés pour son bébé. »
Mais cela n'a pas seulement un impact économique et physique.
L'accouchement est, et sera toujours, un grand moment psychologique.
Une enseignante m'a dit :
« J'ai repris le travail 8 semaines après la naissance de mon fils.
Je souffrais déjà d'anxiété,
mais les attaques de panique que j'ai eues avant de reprendre le travail
étaient insupportables. »
Statistiquement,
plus le congé maternité est court, plus la mère est susceptible de souffrir
de troubles de l'humeur post-partum
tels que la dépression et l'anxiété.
Parmi les conséquences potentielles de ces troubles,
le suicide est la 2ème cause de décès la plus répandue chez les femmes
durant la première année post-partum.
Je n'ai jamais rencontré cette femme,
mais je trouve difficile d'ignorer son histoire.
« Je sens un chagrin et une colère immenses d'avoir perdu un temps
formateur essentiel et irremplaçable avec mon fils.
L'accouchement m'a laissée complètement brisée.
Pendant des mois, je ne me rappelle que des cris : des coliques, m'ont-ils dit.
En moi, je perdais pied.
Chaque matin, je me demandais combien de temps encore j'allais tenir.
On m'a autorisée à emmener mon bébé au travail.
Je fermais la porte de mon bureau pendant que je le berçais,
le suppliant d’arrêter de crier pour que je n'ai pas d'ennuis.
Je me cachais derrière cette porte chaque jour
et pleurais pendant qu'il criait.
Je pleurais aux toilettes en lavant le tire-lait.
Je pleurais chaque jour sur le chemin pour aller et rentrer du travail.
J'avais promis à mon responsable que le travail inachevé au bureau
serait fait chez moi le soir.
Je pensais que quelque chose clochait en moi si je n'arrivais pas à gérer ça. »
Voilà pour les mamans.
Qu'en est-il des bébés ?
Notre pays s’intéresse-t-il aux millions de bébés
qui naissent et dont les mères travaillent ?
Je dis que non.
Pas avant qu'ils aient l'âge de travailler,
payer des impôts, servir dans l'armée.
On leur dit : « On se verra dans 18 ans. »
et d'ici là, ils se débrouillent.
Si je dis ça, c'est parce que les enfants dont la mère
est à la maison pendant 12 semaines ou plus
ont plus de chance d'être vaccinés
et de passer les contrôles de santé la première année.
Ces enfants sont plus protégés contre les maladies invalidantes et mortelles
mais on cache tout cela derrière des images comme celle-là.
Le message des États-Unis pour les nouvelles mères actives et leurs bébés
est que vous devez être redevables pour le temps que vous passez ensemble
et que vous êtes une gêne pour l'économie
et pour votre employeur.
Ce discours de gratitude ressort dans beaucoup des histoires que j'entends.
Une femme m'a dit :
« J'ai repris 8 semaines après ma césarienne
parce que mon mari était au chômage.
Sans moi, ma fille a eu un retard de croissance.
Elle refusait le biberon.
Elle a commencé à perdre du poids.
Heureusement, mon responsable était très compréhensif.
Il a permis à ma mère de ramener
mon bébé sous oxygène et surveillance,
quatre fois par jour pour que je puisse la nourrir. »
Dans le monde, il n'y a que quelques pays
qui n'accordent pas de congés payés aux nouvelles mères.
Saurez-vous dire lesquels ?
Les 8 premiers ont 8 millions d'habitants tous réunis.
La Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée, Surinam et les petites îles
de Micronésie, les îles Marshall, Nauru, Niue, Palau et Tonga.
Le neuvième est les États-Unis
avec 320 millions d'habitants.
Et c'est tout.
C'est la fin de la liste.
Toutes les autres économies
ont trouvé un moyen d'accorder des congés payés
à ceux qui œuvrent pour l'avenir de leur pays,
mais on dit qu'on ne peut pas le faire,
que le marché règlera le problème,
puis nous félicitons les sociétés qui accordent plus de congés payés
aux femmes qui ont déjà un niveau d'études et un salaire plus élevés.
Vous rappelez-vous de ces 88% ?
Ces femmes à revenus moyens et faibles n'y participeront pas.
Nous savons qu'il y a des coûts économiques, financiers, physiques
et psychologiques énormes à cette approche.
Nous avons décidé, décidé, c'est voulu,
de répercuter ces coûts directement sur les mères actives et leurs bébés.
Nous savons que le prix à payer est plus élevé
pour les femmes à faibles revenus,
et encore plus pour les femmes de couleur.
Nous l'acceptons quand même.
C'est une honte pour l'Amérique,
mais c'est aussi un risque.
Que se passerait-il si ces « choix » personnels d'avoir des bébés
devenaient des « choix » personnels de ne pas en avoir ?
Une femme m'a dit :
« Devenir mère est difficile, cela ne devrait pas être traumatisant.
Quand nous parlons d’élargir notre famille,
nous pensons au temps que nous aurons pour prendre soin de moi et de mon enfant.
Si nous devons revivre la même chose qu'avec le premier,
nous n'aurons pas d'autre enfant. »
Le seuil de renouvellement aux États-Unis pour une population stable
est de 2,1 enfants par femme.
Aujourd'hui, nous en avons 1,86.
Nous avons besoin que les femmes aient des bébés
et nous dissuadons vivement les femmes actives d'en avoir.
Que se passerait-il pour la main d’œuvre, l'innovation, le PIB,
si, une par une, les mères actives de ce pays décidaient
qu'elles ne supporteraient pas d'avoir plus d'un enfant ?
Je suis ici aujourd'hui avec une seule idée à partager,
vous avez deviné ce que c'est.
Cela fait longtemps que les pays les plus puissants du monde
offrent un congé national payé
aux personnes œuvrant pour le futur du pays
et aux bébés qui représentent ce futur.
La natalité est d'intérêt général.
Ces congés devraient être subventionnés par l’État
et cela sans exception pour les petites entreprises,
selon la durée de l'emploi ou pour les entrepreneurs.
Ils devraient pouvoir être partagés entre les partenaires.
J'ai beaucoup parlé des mères,
mais la présence des deux parents est importante.
Pas une femme de plus ne devrait retourner au travail
alors qu'elle boîte et saigne.
Pas une famille de plus ne devrait vider son compte épargne
pour acheter quelques jours de repos, de rétablissement, d'attachement.
Pas un enfant fragile de plus
ne devrait aller directement de la couveuse à la crèche
parce que ses parents ont épuisé tout leur maigre temps
assis à l'hôpital.
Pas une famille active de plus ne devrait entendre que la collision
de leur travail, dont nous avons besoin, et leur devoir de parents
est un problème en soi.
Le piège est que c'est dévorant quand cela arrive à une nouvelle famille
et qu'une famille avec un bébé est plus vulnérable que jamais
financièrement.
Et qu'une mère ne peut se permettre de dénoncer la situation.
Mais nous avons tous une voix.
J'en ai fini, fini d'avoir des bébés,
et si vous comptez en avoir,
si vous en avez,
si vous ne souhaitez pas en avoir.
Cela ne devrait pas importer.
Nous devons arrêter d'en faire un problème de mère
ou un problème féminin.
C'est un problème américain.
Nous devons arrêter de croire au mensonge raconté par ces images,
elles ne doivent plus nous réconforter.
Il faut se demander pourquoi on nous dit
que cela ne peut pas fonctionner,
alors que cela fonctionne partout dans le monde.
Nous devons reconnaitre que cette réalité américaine
est à notre déshonneur et notre péril.
Car cela n'est pas,
cela n'est pas
et cela n'est pas non plus ce à quoi ressemble une mère active.
(Applaudissements)